it is time now for the uplift at eight
where we share stories that will bring
some joy to your day I always say this
is the best part of your day this
morning we have an epic dance battle and
you'll never guess who stole the show
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
hey oh she tossed it right back to him
that is Yolanda Turner she is an eighth
grade teacher at Sumner High School oh
Tampa Florida oh okay okay Miss Yolanda
uh it's like Tina Turner
Turner was dueling it out with one of
her students during an exam break before
the holidays the video has gone viral
with millions of views Turner says it
was all a surprise to even her
I had no idea he was gonna you know come
at me like he did so that's when I
turned up or as they've been saying in
the comments I activated the cheat code
for the next level
cheat code for the next level okay okay
uh Miss Turner's motto for her students
is less chatter more matter meaning take
care of business first and then we can
have some fun oh that was so that was so
good she's like I didn't know he was
going to come at me well come at me like
that I saw the student said said you
know when he tapped her in he was like
I've never seen a teacher dance like
that he probably thought it wasn't going
to go down like that I thought he was
going to show her up so who won
who won for sure
awesome I love it